[Music]
I'm the one
all right so podcast here what episode
are we on Rob can you tell me is a 290
is a 289 280 2K 280 20 away from 30. 20
away from uh 300 300 300 episodes you're
good anyways yes because I'm reading the
message on the text at the same time we
got some announcements to make today
which is pretty awesome I'm excited
about this I've been working on this for
13 months and it's official I make it a
momentarily I thought you said 13 years
13 13 months but I've been a dream since
13 years old well 13 14 years old wow
but we got some stories let me first
tell you what the stories are and then
we'll get right into the announcement I
don't know we said Sports I was wearing
a Joe Borough Jersey I saw you wearing
my Aaron judge I said I'll put on the
Ruth and you uh can somebody send Adam a
Jersey please watch Adam get like 50
jerseys this week I was wearing a wife
beater and you made me put on a jersey
yeah because I want you to stay married
I want you to stay married so anyways
here's some of the stories we got we
haven't talked to the economy for a
while this last week we had some guests
on that uh one of them was a was against
delegating and the other guest that we
had on was a brilliant comedian and if
you know if you watch the podcast you
know who I'm referencing but it was a
blast both of them yes or no amazing oh
yesterday yesterday's guys anti-delegate
anti-delegator Jeff he gave me a book
signed books this is nine and ten stuck
together so it was crazy one of the
funniest into his sense of humor on the
way he took it I was so much anyways
okay so there was a fight yesterday
shift didn't have a good day yesterday
everybody listen today it's about firing
everybody you know indicting everybody
and silencing everybody it's just a mess
right now in politics which makes for uh
entertaining news uh so we can talk
about that MSNBC president is open to a
trump Town Hall angering liberals uh
which if he knows what happened to
Alaska who got fired maybe this can
happen to this guy as well economy
Adam's got some stuff to talk about the
economy the SMP is back to its numbers
if not even better record-breaking
numbers than ever before does this mean
you know all this stuff about the
financial crisis is not going to be
happening we'll find out what he has to
say Zuckerberg wants to fight Elon which
is interesting to see what happens there
Pentagon what is the most money folks
you ever had missing I want you to think
about this what is the most money you
ever had missing Rob what's the most
money you ever had missing like you were
like where's that hundred dollars
where's that thousand dollars honestly
65 I just lost it the other day and I
was really bummed out and then I saw
this story well 65 000 the Pentagon
accounting error provides extra 6.2
billion dollars to Ukraine no you don't
say and they're not even asking for it
back they're just saying it's future
money that we're gonna make you such
great people I mean when you think about
this kind of things you almost want to
be Ukraine to to get the aid that you're
getting oh my God anyways so
Zuckerberg's master plan to kill off
Twitter revealed it's pretty dark but
we'll talk about it
fetcher sees long way to go on inflation
fight BlackRock and JP Morgan helped to
set up Ukraine reconstruction uh Bank
vacant officer piling up Silicon Valley
Progressive leaders encouraged to buy
media outlets for boosting influence
over Americans by the way great strategy
unfortunately there is no conservative
leaders encouraging them to bind media
Outlets so you got to give it up to
these progressives U.S housing starts
surged most since 2016 exceeds all
estimates we'll talk about that housing
shortage fuels price bidding wars as
homes for sale hit record low and then
we got a couple of feuds here one is uh
the one between Kevin O'Leary and Mark
Cuban about woke Disney's got the
elemental which features non-binary
character flops in opening weekend we'll
talk about that and whatever's going on
with this Titanic missing you know it's
just some strange stuff and it's from
homelessness cities and apparently
officially this week the richest man in
the world
is no longer a long mask
it's officially Andrew and Tristan Tate
because they only they own 21 million
Bitcoin really they're worth 600 billion
dollars according to this artist oh wow
hey where is an accounting we covered
that as well anyways let me tell you
what the announcement to me is here's
what the announcement is so 1.4 foot
none of it just everybody knows the only
person here that knows is Tom no one can
I be honest with you I'm and you should
give kudos to Kelly and everybody that's
out there I've been I've been I swear to
God
no no listen I swear to God on
everything that means anything to me
I've been trying to find information I'm
like listen I'll take you to dinner I'll
give you I'll send I'll venmo give me a
hint they're good actually I swear to
God she didn't tell me anything and I
was like okay I go perhaps you'd be
proud of you all right you're promising
dinner is probably not so so here's talk
here's what it is guys from from the the
moment I came to America and you know as
a kid having a dream you know Sports all
this stuff reading Daily News reading
L.A times you know following basketball
Magic versus Jordan I've won finals in
1991 or you know baseball relating to uh
who Juan Gonzalez was at Texas Rangers
my height the swing I wanted to emulate
or or the Mickey Mantle card that you
know I wanted one day now I got a few
Mickey Mantle cards or you know the
dream of Babe Ruth cards oh my God babe
or this or that or football all these
things
this has been in the works it's been a
dream it's crazy I got a call last year
about a conversation of if I have any
interest of being a a minority owner of
any team stop it oh my shut up and stop
it I I at first I was going back and
forth so I said let me get my lawyers
involved we got the lawyers involved and
after the lawyers getting involved and
I'm like is this real are we doing this
are we nothing yes and then here's the
options I said no I'm not interested in
this not interested but there's this one
option this man who was on the board of
this team he's coming up for retirement
and he wants to sell his shares would
you entertain this
and I said sure So anyways long story
short effective last Friday after
background checks with MLB after 40
articles I've written after all of these
things that's happened effective last
Friday I'm a minority owner of the New
York Yankees
um
let's go baby
this happened last Friday we're in
Bermuda I get the news uh what lawyer
calls the the CFO Tony from uh Yankees
congratulations you're officially part
of the team are you kidding me when I
went to when I went to the Schultz
podcast my idea was I was going to
announce this on the Schultz podcast
what so I'm like hey you know we
rescheduled I was like why is it got
rescheduled trust me there's a reason
why I'm rescheduled like and then you
know so when I went to New York it was a
best meeting let me tell you what
happened It's the final meeting that
determines it all we've already done a
bunch of different interviews and I'm
sitting in a room with Randy Levine okay
who was the president of the Yankees you
got a line here who's been with the
organization since 1975 he's pretty much
the CEO he's you know he's a decision
maker he's up there big big decision
he's an American success story he
started at the bottom he was like one of
these guys just selling stuff and he
made it to the top and he got Tony on
this side uh the CFO and we're sitting
having a conversation and then Hal uh
steinburner walks in sitting here we
have a nice uh 45 minute one hour
conversation so tell us about this and
what about this and what about that and
what about this I said listen guys
here's the only thing you need to um
loud have opinions I you know I love
America I'm a capitalist I'm this and
that's okay great you know here's how
this works and then Hal gave this and
he's the boss and he's this is that
incredible experience got a private tour
the entire back they took us everywhere
the lawn took uh to the coroner office
we sat down we had an incredible
conversation with them uh look I'm
excited about this this is a dream this
is a part of what uh why we do what we
do and uh it was exciting man to see it
finally do you have any idea that's I
had zero idea I thought we were bringing
somebody on board whatever but the New
York Yankees are the greatest Sports
organization in the history of sports
congrats that is so so we're going to
games then well that's what I was trying
to do that's all we're doing I'm trying
to get it where we're gonna get on the
jet go to New York have dinner at 11
Madison then go to the box you guys
we're gonna meet everybody it was going
to be that whole experience I'm like
schedule keeps it's gonna be conflict
I'm just gonna make the announcement
today
that is I'm a little upset Pat because
I've been rooting against the Yankees
not anymore not anymore since
the 80s almost or years for years yours
and yours now I'm the biggest Yankees
fan oh now I have to go follow the
Yankees we're gonna root for the Yankees
what was it like that deciding moment
where well you guys are in the talks and
what what's that moment where the the
decision is like is it like a
conversation to a lawyer did it hit you
up personally what is that oh it's it's
it's a listen it's a long process took
nearly 13 months it's a long process
background check everything everything
okay they have to go it's the MLB you're
a representation uh like you have to so
but anyways you know eventually when
this what what this is to get in this is
a stepping stone to if you ever want to
become a majority owner now they've done
the background now you have the Run rate
so a lot of the majority owners first
start off as minority owners eventually
you know so I mean the plan is the plan
but this was a this was the owner of the
Red Sox started in South Florida as a
minority owner of the Marlins there you
go so
um moving forward we're wearing Yankees
Peter over there who's the Red Sox
I hate you I can't believe you're doing
it bang the door that was Peter banging
on the door can I just say one thing
yeah oh my God that's only in America
yeah that's right go ahead made an Iran
yeah escapes Iran yeah 1991
November 2019.90 I come here 1990 lives
in a refugee camp in Germany
escapes Christian in Iran escapes
everything that's going on with the
mulas and Ayatollah comes here
1.8 GPA in high school
nobody thought you would do anything in
your life he didn't think it's 20 years
in the Army U.S army veteran we all know
those stories
Maguire and you're supposed to cry now
yeah no not at all but this is more of a
message to anybody the victim mentality
yep
everything you do with PHP everything
you built with valuetainment now you're
a part owner a money minority owner of
the greatest sports franchise in
American history oh my God Only in
America it's it's in it's in the world
there's only about you know the the
Mount Rushmore of sports franchises is
the Yankees are on that and you're
number one absolutely and most
championships and on a global soccer
basis even Man U is below that Dallas
Cowboys are up there but this is the
preeminent sports franchise in the world
incredible and by the way I mean you
have to so let me tell you what I did in
Bermuda Matt's Apollo if you're watching
this money smart guy when I told you I'm
only taking you because I wanted to keep
it low-key this is what I was going to
take you to he's like are we going are
we not going to know what was going on
so we're gonna still go Matt just hang
tight I'll give you the dates I was
gonna wait till another day another time
but I have something for you really I
have something for you okay okay so I
didn't expect this we had zero clue what
the announcement would be but with the
only in America thing being born in Iran
made in America but what people don't
know I mean people know but if you if
you peel back the onion of pbd you're a
proud Armenian Assyrian yes right very
your father is Syrian your mother is
Armenian now Armenia still exists yeah
Syria is the Babylonians everything that
was the scattered people so I was just
in Israel I went to Jerusalem I actually
FaceTime me you're like
I'm buying the Yankees leave me alone
but I don't know anything about Armenian
culture but I went to the number one
culture store in all of Jerusalem
Armenians I facetimed with the lady I
said I want to get this guy something
special I don't know anything about
Armenian culture
get me the best thing here that that
this guy would love and appreciate can I
give it to you now sure all right yeah
let's see what oh let's see what's going
on with what it is here we go sir oh my
God is that I've already opened it up a
little bit so you don't have to like
spend all your time opening it up
there's a few things they they threw in
open up the big one first okay so
there's three things in there
so she said she thought you would love
something like this this is from this is
from Jerusalem
in Jerusalem it's the called the hotel
it's four quarters there's the Armenian
section the Jewish section the Christian
section in the Muslim section okay and
this was the number one store in all of
The Armenian section
this is The Lord's Prayer
from Jerusalem wow from Jerusalem this
is from Jerusalem this is insane thank
you I can't read good even even again
you know sometimes you know if someone
gets like a Chinese tattoo and they
think it means Spirit yeah and then it
turns out that it's something obnoxious
that's awesome I guess in Armenian
culture this is a a symbol of of life
and peace and prosperity yes the peacock
it is in every pretty much in every
Armenian home yes yes do you have
anything I don't have anything like this
here it is I appreciate you man
according to man baby thank you of
course and there's one little extra
thing in there that she threw in she's
like since you've done all this let me
throw in a little extra Armenian pipe
why would you give me an Armenian place
it looks like a pipe that's hilarious
but it's not that's amazing well thank
you of course brother man this is I
appreciate it I'm not gonna sell you my
shares
okay but I think I could speak for the
whole team we are super proud super
excited so freaking awesome and
everything that we got well listen you
know none of this happens uh uh it comes
with a team we've had some great people
over the years this wouldn't happen
without Tom uh this wouldn't happen
without the Gen uh being in my corner uh
all the PHP people they know who they
are what they've done all the vegetarian
people it's been a lot of work this is
this has been a this has been an effort
for a long time and by the way man you
can also give credit to the enemies I'm
about to have a book being launched in
the next on December 5th is going to
come out I'm excited about this book
here the title of the book is called
choose your enemies wiser I am thankful
for also many of the enemies over the
years because without you it would have
been boring this is an exciting game
here's the crazy thing though as wild as
this is I am telling you right now who
just getting warmed up I wish people
knew Tom what we're doing Beyond closing
by the way it's been 100 radio silent on
my side and my phone is getting blown up
because a certain girl wants to know if
you know anybody because she wants a
career in SportsCenter I know I know who
she is and she'll she'll get the next
time we're going she's going to go with
us it's blowing up right now PVD do me
do me one last listen let me tell you
yesterday the Box we were getting was 16
I said guys can we get a different box
they're working on getting us a box with
26 or 30 people to take everybody there
you know it's gonna be friends
if we walk in there this is what we
signed up for I'm gonna cry it's gonna
be great do me one favor yeah this
actually might be the most important
message if and when there comes a time
they ask you to throw out the opening oh
my God
warm up that arm we can't have a moment
I'm gonna bring coaches to work on me to
say listen work on this arm there's some
kind of a 80 mile an hour pitch here
maybe more like a 45 mile an hour pitch
but anyways as Jesus said to Obama don't
bounce it they will boo you yeah that's
a true story that's what he told him
listening super excited I want to get
into the podcast but I wanted to make
this announcement that we did this
beautiful and it's awesome I appreciate
all the support uh uh by the way while
we're going into this before we get into
the podcast let me real quick give a
shout out to the sponsor of this podcast
Masterworks uh the economy right now is
strange one minute it's the end of the
world Adam's about to show the agreed
fear index that we'll look at next
minute people are excited next minute
people are afraid nobody knows what's
really going on but here's what you can
count on long term everybody I know that
is investors who call me with different
opportunities I tell them call me with
any non-duplicatable assets what
Masterworks allows you to do for some of
you that appreciate art and you want to
have some alternative Investments but
you can't afford to buy Picasso A banks
or or any of the Civil Warhol they allow
you to buy shares in those pieces of Art
and when they grow and it sells you get
to sell your shares so it's a way of you
know diversifying your portfolio so if
you've never taken advantage of
Masterworks I highly recommend you go on
the link below I think at this point
they have over 740 000 users with 750
million dollars of assets under
management if you want to participate to
see if you qualify click on the link
below go see Masterworks and take
advantage of what these guys have to
offer okay let's get right into the
economy uh first things first Tom fed
share Seas long way to go on inflation
fight this is a New York Times
story when you turn on the news you'll
see Kramer saying it's back all these
fearing and all this it's done
everything's great everything in the
base like well listen it's only seven
stocks that are driving the market no
stop being pessimistic things are great
look at what's going on they're not
raising the rates anymore here's what
Powell says Powell address lawmakers
stating in the United States has a long
way to go in tackling inflation power
emphasize inflation pressures continue
to run High and the process of getting
inflation back down to two percent has a
long way to go the fed's recent decision
to keep interest rates on hand unchanged
after a series of increases does not
indicate victory over inflation power
will explain given how far we've come it
makes it makes sense to move rates
higher but to do so at a more moderate
Pace we compared it to slow
slowing down as you get closer to your
destination seeking a delegate balance
and cooling economic growth without
overdoing it the central bank's economic
projections suggests the possibility of
two more quarter point rate increases
this year so Tom when you hear the story
you see where the s p is at you see
where the market's at are we done with
the market crash should we still stay
paranoid are these rates done going up
you know or property value is going to
go up what's really going on with the
economy well I want to give I want to
encourage everybody to think of it this
way think of the economy right now in
three chapters chapter one is the
financial economy you look up and you
see the stock market doing good oh the S
P 500 it's not far off from an all-time
high why the bounce back in tech stocks
the things that are driving that are
much different through US economy and
we'll just and I'll bring it up at one
point do you remember all the people
that were laid off by Tech those people
represent expenses so now these tech
companies have less expenses some of
them haven't seen Revenue up a lot but
if you have the same revenue and less
expense you have more profit the stock
price goes up so that's what's going on
it is Tech driving the stock market now
that economy doesn't translate to the
personal economy because for those
stocks to bounce back what do we just
talk about a bunch of layoffs so there
are people that are hurting and we're
going to talk a little bit later about
amazing things are going on in
commercial real estate and housing in
California as a result of that so the
financial economy is one thing and you
see at the stock market the personal
economy is quite another and we just
talked about how layoffs are impacting
people now you step back to the housing
economy which is directly connected to
the personal economy because everybody
needs a house whether it's rent or
whether it's buy and right now
the FED is still impacting the personal
economy because interest rates aren't
going to come down allowing people to
buy more houses for a while and the FED
is saying we think it's slowing down but
they are probably going to raise the
rate in July and then Skip and then
raise the rate in October what that
means is this seven percent mortgage
we're seeing right now good credit
30-year fixed uh is still six seven five
to seven right now that's probably not
going to change which means you're going
to still have pressure on housing so
what's going on remember you're actually
seeing three pictures at once you're
seeing the stock market you're seeing
the housing market you're seeing the
personal Market
so but here's a part-time that I gotta I
gotta bring this out for the real estate
people because they're they're giving
this argument and you got to give them
credit so on page 17 if you want to go
to it housing shortage fuels price
bidding wars at homes for sale hits
record low housing shortage fuels
bidding wars as homes for sale hit
record low U.S housing market faces a
record low inventory of homes for sale
with 1.4 million available homes in May
sparking intense bidding wars Redfin
attributes the shortage to homeowners
feeling trapped by Rising mortgage rates
resulting in seven seven point one
percent year-over-year decrease in home
Inventory in May 37 percent of homes
sold above listing prices raising
concerns about escalating bidding wars
new home uh construction reached a three
decade High driven by the motivation of
Builders to meet demand amid low
existing home Inventory and then at the
same time U.S housing starts surged most
since 2016 talking about what's
happening there in may all of a sudden
the largest margin since 2016 with a
21.7 jump to a
1.63 million annualized rate surprising
all Economist projections single-family
home building also Rose by 18 and a half
percent to a uh to reach an 11 month
High when you see these numbers what is
this telling you so there's an
interesting puzzle to break in here in
it but it'll make perfect sense with a
few simple points Point number one when
they say 37 of homes sold above lifting
prices they don't tell you that that was
the fewest number of homes sold in four
years so 37 percent of the fewest homes
sold so there's actually not a lot of
sales going on for one simple reason
Vinnie if you had a three percent
mortgage and you say wow maybe I'll sell
my home and make 300 000 on it versus
what I bought then what then what do you
do you have to go get a seven percent
mortgage on your new house or a high
rent or lease price if you want to do
something in the interim you're not
going to do that what are you going to
do stay in your three percent mortgage
home you're also going to delay
tournament moving to Florida Arizona or
Palm Springs and you're going to keep
your home for you know maybe we'll just
wait a year before we downsize and move
that's happening so the first thing has
happened there's not enough houses on
the market so the the and when there's
few homes on the market it's a shortage
and prices go up now then you've got
seven percent interest rates but prices
are up so the home builders are saying
now wait a minute inflation makes labor
up to build a house it makes materials
up build a house but if Pat and I had a
house built house building company we
would say hey Pat
prices are at an all-time high and the
fed's not lower in rates probably for a
couple years Pat we could start houses
right now because there's profit to be
made because we don't we're not going to
be selling them at low prices we're
going to be selling them at high prices
Pat says you know Tom you're right let's
see if you can get permits and open up
another home they're at homes and a
little development to build so the home
builders are seeing high prices as an
opportunity to build and make profits at
the same time many people are staying in
their homes not selling them so though
there's a variety of headlines going
around in there but the the moral of the
story at the end of the road is the
housing market is constrained but
Builders see an opportunity to make a
buck can you pull up this link this is
Jerome Powell he's talking about the
interest rates and one of the folks from
Fox Business go to 37 minutes and 10
seconds if you can ask some a great
question Tom and you have to see how he
responds because right they're perfect I
want you to watch this if you can there
you go watch this real quick with the
question that's being asked of them
thank you for taking the question um Mr
chairman Edward Lawrence with Fox
Business so I want to go back to
comments you made about um in the past
about unsustainable fiscal path the CBO
projects the federal deficit to be 2.8
trillion uh in 10 years the CBO also
says that federal debt will be 52
trillion by 2033. at what point do you
talk more firmly with lawmakers about
fiscal responsibility because I'm
assuming monetary policy cannot handle a
loan the inflation or keep that
inflation in check with the higher level
spending
I don't do that that's really not my job
we we we we hope and expect that other
policy makers will respect our
independence on on monetary policy
and we don't see ourselves as uh as you
know the judges of appropriate fiscal
policy I will say and many of my
predecessors have said that we are on an
unsustainable fiscal path and that needs
to be addressed over time but I think
trying to get into uh into that with
with lawmakers would be would be kind of
uh
inappropriate given our independence and
our need to stick to our knitting but
you can pause it right there by the way
what an answer he's right but you know
what he's asking him he's asking him all
this work you're doing to lower
inflation but Congress keeps pumping out
money into the economy it's as if you're
no needed like like Congress is telling
Powell yeah everybody says you're the
most powerful man in America no you're
not we're the most powerful men and
women in America not you
they can give you as much recognition as
they want as long as we pump money into
the economy the economy and the Market's
going to keep going up and it's going to
be fine it's like this is not a healthy
we keep delaying the pain that we got to
go through nope let's go into that nope
let's go into that so as much as
everybody is celebrating right now yeah
this is going back by the way to all the
Realtors and loan officers
congratulations to you but guess what
we're going back to fake success again
so this time around
to some of the folks that made a lot of
money and had a lot of fake success but
didn't save it and you lost it all this
time around instead of jumping into that
Rolls-Royce a little too early wait
three years if you can make the same
amount of income three years in a row
and you start having some Investments
that are paying you outside of just your
refinance and houses you're selling get
tighter with your own Investments I got
friends that did it right they're not
affected at all matter of fact they're
doing great for them so because they
made the right Investments they're okay
but some of the guys that lived a fast
life they lost everything and they're in
a bad situation unfortunately I've been
through this when I was in my early 20s
and I made the money and I was like boom
this thing disappeared wait a minute
what was this all about you got to learn
that lesson and last but not least
if there's more inventories there's less
inventory that means they're not selling
more here's the other question Tom
the same loan that I'm getting if values
are going up no that house was 400 000
out 700 000. 700 000 now one million did
my income also increase by 40 percent
has the median income in America
increase nope it is the average income
that we all of a sudden get a massive
raise in our salary
are most people going to be able to
afford these increases to buy those
homes I don't think so so we're still
it's still going to be early on what to
do with this I know you have some
thoughts on the economy if you want to
kind of go through your uh fear greed
index and kind of share with us your
thoughts on that point backhand ratios
you know what back-end ratios are
already being uh evaluated for a loan
but a lot of banks had gone conservative
down to 32.35 and what we're reading now
is banks are up to 40.
so we we cover the fear greed index from
time to time right
um basically be fearful when people are
greedy be greedy when people are fearful
and we've we we reference this you know
once in a monthly quarterly what have
you the last time I think we did this
was maybe like two three months ago I
remember six months ago it was extreme
fear yeah I don't check this every
single day I don't check the market I
used to you know red green red green red
green red green and everything like that
I checked it today no clue what to
expect did not know where the fear grade
index would be let's take a look at
where it is today
boom extreme greed 79. actually a week
ago was I think 83 scroll down just a
little bit
okay
keep going
now I'll go back up all right
um oh I should say it on the right there
there you go yeah so one year ago one
year ago in the economy 26 extreme fear
okay extreme people were paranoid last
year in 2022 the market the S P 500 was
down what Tom 18
incredible okay down 18
recession yep two consecutive quarters
of negative GDP growth is it a recession
how do you define a recession the White
House has changed the definition they're
moving the goal post what's a recession
I don't know the housing market what's
going on right now your word my profits
go yeah but slowly but surely Chuck a
Chocolate Tree
U.S economy bounce back baby so right
now I think as of today uh 2022 the S P
500 was down 18
um for the first six months of the year
I think we're up 15 we're closing in on
um all time all-time highs again I
remember in 2020 do you guys remember
this
stock market was approaching thirty
thousand it's March
2020.
boom covet hits Black Swan event you
don't know what to expect Market tanks
down 35 you know you're in a group chat
with all your friends he's like yeah I
heard about this a couple weeks ago I
got out people are like [__] you why
don't you tell me buddy like now I got
out of the market I put my cash out boom
six months later markets back and then
some record highs okay so people are
like should I have taken it out should I
have not you know they say it's not
about timing the market it's about time
in the market play the long game I'm not
a day trader I'm a decade Trader that's
how investing works you can't I know so
many day traders who claim they make
millions but I know so many who lose so
much freaking money that's very good
feedback you're given you ain't lying if
you're playing the long game you're
going to be fine if you're a day trader
versus a decade Trader what a statement
to say yeah I'm not a day trader I'm a
decade Trader that's that's the best way
to look at business life parenting
relationships friendships Investment
Portfolio it's a very good feedback
there thank you sir but can I give one
more thing okay so
um you know the whole premise is buying
the S P 500 just why buy individual
stocks when you can buy the entire
market right why'd be an active investor
you can be a passive investor and
basically just keep your money in the
market and just don't look at it and
just look at it 10 years later holy [__]
I'm a millionaire that's what happened
to me so
um but you know I remember uh Tom what
was it Fang f-a-a-n-g a handful of years
ago that's everyone's obsessed with
paying Guff yeah if you added one more
and that was what Facebook Amazon Apple
Netflix nobody's using that energy right
and then Google and then what do they
add to that there's uh Amazon and apple
and Amazon so now
not not the acronym guy now the new
number is eminent okay because there's
seven stocks that are basically carrying
the S P 500 these days these seven
stocks make up 26 of the s p uh 500
total weight
um these seven stocks which I'll give
you right now this eminent Apple
alphabet meta AKA Facebook Microsoft
Amazon and then the new darling of the
last few years in video and then you got
Tesla which basically bounced back we
all know what Elon Musk is doing 107 on
January interesting to me we just talked
about in uh 2023 in the last six months
the Market's up 15 after last year's
down 18 but
um
If you eliminate If you eliminate those
seven stocks
right from the overall numbers the
market will be down close to one percent
so those seven stocks are basically
carrying the market but this is why you
need to buy the entire Market because
let's just use one case as an example
I'm going to borrow your terminology
case example if you were shorting meta
because meta last year they changed
their name from Facebook to meta
disaster everyone thinks that they're
going to be partying in the metaverse
hold on let me buy some real assets meta
was down 64 in 2022. 64 people were
calling for the death of meta what do
you got what are you doing Mark
Zuckerberg you freaking idiot changing
your name Facebook to meta what's meta's
uh stock price up this year 98.5 bounce
back Facebook meta so after land off how
many yeah how many layoffs are
profitable there you go so
um
play the long game my friends that's how
you do it by the way did you guys hear
about what Twitter just did no did you
hear the news about Twitter time or no
uh like this morning it's not breaking
this is this is the the amount of
employees now they have based on CNBC
Rob I think I may have even texted you
this
type in type and see and type in there
you go right there click on that right
there Twitter Tom look at this tell me
this isn't crazy Twitter is now down to
fewer than 550 Engineers what Twitter so
zoom in a little bit internal records
show that Twitter has shed about 80 of
its employees in silamos took over wow
head count is hover on 1300 full-time
employees today with fewer than 550
full-time Engineers one former Twitter
engineer says that the remaining team
will be spread thin and will likely have
a hard time maintaining this service
while adding new features in addition to
1300 full-time employees the new owner
CEO Elon Musk has authorized about 130
people from its other companies
including Tesla SpaceX and a boring
company to work for the social media
business wow think about that when you
create a unique culture question came
about
uh on one of the masterminds we were
doing this week a guy says you know
matter of fact it was actually a
conversation I was having yesterday with
a good friend a guy says you know what
do you do in a situation like this when
you're taking over a company and you're
Elon okay do you fire everybody they
don't like working for a guy like you or
you don't you're not letting people work
from home you want people to be there
every day you want people driving and
all of a sudden like they see you as a
dictator Elon they don't see you as a
what's the word a uh understanding
compassionate empathetic yeah you know
somebody who values lowering anxiety and
all this stuff listen anxiety if you are
afraid of anxiety and and mental issues
you go through don't join a startup on
don't work for a Founder let me say that
one more time if you're worried about
your anxiety never work for a Founder
never be part of a startup go work for a
big company that nobody knows what the
hell you're doing when you leave work if
you leave Friday at 2 30 nobody knows a
big company at a small company you leave
work at 2 30. everybody knows when you
leave out 2 30. some people don't like
that but you know what else is the
benefit of working with a guy like Elon
here's what happens when you work with a
guy like Elon five ten years later when
there is a go in public opportunity or
an experience like that and you're
sitting there saying did you see how
much money just simply counted these
people now we're like regular people
that that's like a big check yeah but
don't act like you're worth it yeah so
this is a great meeting where Paul
wanted to give you my feedback about
what's taking place here but you have to
you have to I asked Peter I said Peter
you ever work with a crazy founder
before not like this ever seen something
like this I'm like well that's what's
going to take so it's not for everybody
but good for Elon for driving it I gotta
tell you to me when I see what's going
on yesterday I um
they didn't posted a video with us
talking to Mary yassan yeah and man son
what a sweetheart he is he responded can
you pull up the Tweet with him
responding this is a sweet guy on the
level of like uh there's a sweetheart
there's certain words I would say when I
think about a guy like this like they
you know awesome yeah go up a little bit
keep going up it's somewhere in a
reaction if you just keep going up uh no
you were good yeah keep going up keep
going up keep going up
he retweeted and he responded to it and
I want to uh Rob to show the guy tweets
like you know he's tweeted 160 000 times
150 000 times it's a lot of times he's
written like 17 Bibles is what he's
written just based on his tweets okay
right there zoom in right there on his
response and I have no idea who you are
but since you're asking and assuming go
actually read the book especially the
chapter on Gish Galloping and then come
back to me all may become clear to you
Maddie I am enamored by your Fame and uh
I'm I'm so amazed by how amazing and a
famous person you are and more power to
you keep kicking ass with what you got
going on there but the point is when
you're talking about all these things
that we're doing here with the uh with
the business right when you're going
through a certain Market
these guys are still defending Peter
hotez every day Peter Hotes is tweeting
20 times sharing articles of people
saying why he shouldn't debate RFK so
what do you think when somebody ever if
you go to Peter hotel's Twitter profile
just go to his Twitter profile we've
been talking about the sky lot because
uh by the way Peter I hope you say
thanks to Joe Rogan because we're gonna
show the influence of Joe Rogan check
this out look how many followers he's
got how many followers does he have on
Twitter what's the number 455 write that
down can you write it down so we can
remember
455.1 455.1 okay here we go zoom in a
little bit so we can see all the tweets
skip that one because that one he's
selling covet keep going
uh so keep so he's keep going every one
of these tweets is about why he
shouldn't debate anybody keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going keep going Joe
Rogan's wants a scientist to debate a
vaccine denier turning him down was the
right thing to do Vox next one you know
thank you for Peter Otis for sharing the
new piece from Time Magazine RFK is a
peddling an extraordinary amount of
disinformation about vaccines on a daily
basis so what's the article Peter
retweets RFK is dead wrong about
vaccines Time Magazine right all right
so oh yeah pillar of knowledge there
yeah so so now go to socialblade Rob if
you can do that go to socialblade go to
socialblade.com and then go to the top
right where it says YouTube change it to
Twitter
there you go and type in Peter hotez his
name okay this is called the power of
Joe Rogan
no no you got to put them together you
got to put them together yeah just put
just put the name together there you go
like that perfect so now watch this look
at this go down look how many followers
he was getting go lower slowly go lower
lower lower because that's oh it's not
letting you go Lord keep going Lord
right there he was not getting any
followers all of a sudden Joe Rogan's
made him famous wow a little bit zoom in
yeah Peter hotels was not a household
name that would be 400 38 000 55
000 13
000 3900 it's called The Power of Joe
Rogan something all of these mainstream
media people hate that a Joe Rogan has
this kind of influence where he says one
thing and the Army shows up who is this
guy yeah and by the way he helps you
find your audience because the people
that don't like Joe Rogan say oh my God
there's another person that doesn't like
Joe let me go follow him hey Dr Peter
Hotes I'm your number one fan so Dr
Hotes next time you're in Austin uh I
don't know if Joe has time but if you do
if you're in Austin maybe go to his
Comedy Club have a laugh or two on the
comedians he has there but uh I think
he's sending a Joe Rogan a Christmas
card this is Christmas after all
yeah yeah again you're you're sitting
here wondering who seems like the one
that has Courage the one that is
questioning Authority and the other one
that is defending Authority folks if
you're listening to this you're part of
one of two camps you're questioning
Authority that's forcing people to do
certain things they didn't want to do or
you're you know defending Authority and
now listen I'm not telling you anything
about Law and Order of course there's
something called Law and Order but some
people that Force certain things down
people's throat maybe we want to
question them to see if that was right
and it's not like Pat like questioning
the authority like the authority hasn't
been screwing us forever you've got to
be on the on the other side you're not
this reminds me of when something like
this happens if you have the facts look
at history if you have the facts you're
running to the microphone to debate and
you're Fearless about it when people
have the facts there after that
microphone and they want to be heard
when you don't have the facts you have
all you get all your people to say oh
tell them all the reasons why you
shouldn't do it tell them all the
reasons why you shouldn't do it you know
what it reminds me of Pat it reminds me
of a certain letter in Washington that
had 50 signatures on it that's said
nothing to see here from the in quote
intelligence community and Joe Biden
it's like no no we don't want to talk
about it we just want to look to a
letter that says 50 people saying uh
nothing to see here and I'll sign this
letter that sort of tez is doing right
now he is out there a coward doctor you
are a coward and you are having all of
your friends just basically Embrace
promote and project your cowardice you
refuse to go out and you've got proxies
out there saying oh don't do it to give
yourself the line and the opening not to
do it if you had the fact sir and you
could stand up to the heat of debate sir
you would be in the arena you sir are a
coward Vinnie tell people out there what
it means when someone shouts nothing to
see here yeah like when if you and I'm
pretty sure everybody in the audience
has when you when you go up to like it's
like something has happened and there's
cop cars maybe there's a fire somebody
was killed and whenever a cop goes hey
move along there's nothing to see here
you know what that means it was a mob
hit
yeah there's definitely something to see
there I like Tom I agree it's like you
are the professional and you have people
that aren't a professional in your field
an expert what are you so scared of it's
the truth bro and notice all those fact
Checkers Tom we didn't have fact
Checkers until the truth really started
coming out now you have to check check
our fact get out of here bro they're all
they're all full of crap no honestly
here nothing to see here Tom that was a
that was an interesting response you had
there for uh our friends uh over there
but okay so let's go to the next story
here BlackRock and JP Morgan helped to
set up Ukraine reconstruction Bank this
is a financial time story on page 15.
Tom I'm gonna come to you again today
it's kind of like uh
this dark day economy economy economy we
haven't had this for a minute BlackRock
and JPMorgan Chase are collaborating
with the Ukrainian government to
establish the Ukraine Development Fund a
reconstruction Bank aimed to attract
private investment for rebuilding
projects after the conflict with Russia
the World Bank estimates that Ukraine
would require
411 billion dollars for reconstruction a
figure that has increased due to recent
Rush on attacks the fund aims to raise
low-cost capital from governments donors
and international financial institutions
and leverage it to attract significant
private investment aiming for ratio of
10 to 30 times the initial Capital the
development uh Finance bank will
identify investment opportunity in
sectors like infrastructure climate and
agriculture to make them appealing to
long-term investors what is this really
all about Tom are we tied to this as
taxpayers or is this purely BlackRock
and JP Morgan's money I don't know what
they're with BlackRock and JP Morgan are
going to start with invest so they're
basically raising a fund the fund will
be private investment and in
institutions governments donors so when
it says governments that means taxpayers
so all this money they're raising a fund
we're going to put money in a barrel
what are we going to do we're telling
you that we can give you what did they
just say up to 30X Pat 30X how many
people come and talk to us about
valuetainment Investment Group
Investments and we're talking 2x5x
unlike startups over the first five
years they're talking 30X translation
they're the banks of the world are
coming together because they feel
there's going to be a Feeding Frenzy to
rebuild Ukraine because we know Ukraine
is important they're the breadbasket of
Europe farming and Manufacturing they're
very important and once the Smoke Clears
no metaphor there the smoke of War
clears this thing's going to need to get
rebuilt and these banks are coming in to
build the fund and some of it's going to
be on taxpayers who go do it and if any
of this fails if a war restarts or it's
trips and stumbles you know who's gonna
be the backstop for this
taxpayers because federal government un
are going to come right back in if you
think the bailout of banks Regional
banks on Commercial you know real estate
was bad in America wait do you see the
bailout of a country
so that's that's what's going on here
they are stepping in and you know what
we've seen it before in history folks
we've seen it before it wasn't a bank
but it was Halliburton that got all
those contracts for power stations
um uh sewage treatment plants a big
infrastructure that makes cities go
um you know you know roads power you
know uh Power transport transmission
lines Communications and power plants
remember remember all the contracts said
Halliburton got and people are saying
this is cronyism Dick Cheney made sure
all of his friends at halberton got that
remember all those headlines remember
what's going on let me tell you this is
what's going on but it's just the
banking sign that says hey hey hang on
hang on BlackRock JPMorgan head of the
line we will make the loans you need a
loan for a power plant Vinnie come on in
here we have a fund here
what's the interest on it well we're
going to make 30X on you yeah for the
for the investors that's what's going on
folks this is look Ukraine needs to be
rebuilt but this is we've seen it before
with Halliburton there's some favored
players that are going to come in here
and get it done that's what's going on
and bro James O'Keefe yesterday this was
on page 10 he uh he dropped the
bombshell video that one of uh uh one of
the recruiters at BlackRock Serge Varley
you know what he said he goes war is
real [__] good sorry for my French uh
good for business volatility creates
opportunity to make profit it's exciting
and he also said uh for ten thousand for
ten Grand you can buy a senator it
doesn't matter who wins they're in my
pocket and he said this is the best one
uh buying politicians to the global
market he says uh it's not who is the
president it's who's controlling the
wallet of the president this is somebody
at BlackRock yeah caught on camera so
this is not even hiding Pat just said it
you just said it a few minutes ago we
control the dollars right the FED
controls the rates and things like this
but it's the government that keeps
spending pumping money in there with all
the spending we control it pat when you
were saying we you met the House of
Representatives the U.S Congress right
the drunk Sailors currently spending our
future and speaking of this ten thousand
dollars will get you a senator in your
pocket right there speaking of lining
your pockets uh ten thousand dollars
it's a black rock yeah okay you're
talking about a group a bank a
conglomerate yeah with AUM assets under
management yeah close to 10 trillion is
it 11 11. fact check that's why we got
PVD here and then right behind that and
they're right behind that yeah if you
check it uh right behind that you got
Vanguard what seven and a half trillion
trillion and then State Street what
close to three and a half trillion
dollars so collectively these three
would you call them asset managers what
we call them Banks whatever hedge funds
what do you call those what do you call
it there's massive conglomerates the
it's it's the headset managers like yeah
it's asset manager which is a
combination of head funds and PE so and
it's just Stacks and stacks and Stacks
and stacks of these guys if you add this
all up you got 11 you got seven you got
three and a half you're talking about
over 21 trillion dollars these three
asset managers are close to the GDP of
the entire United States
and above China
you know so what's the GDP of the United
States right now 22 trillion 25 trillion
what is it at this point so China's in
the in the high uh
double digits in uh what 18 trillion
whatever the number is it's freaking
trillions at this point but that's how
powerful BlackRock is so for them to cut
10 grand to buy a little senate or
whatever whatever is nothing it's
nothing it just means how cheap those
guys are but they got they got a lot of
influence man these these companies uh
have a lot of influence on power right
now and they're pushing their weight
they're not slowing down at all
um let's see here with the story of uh
Disney Disney Elemental which features
non-binary characters flops and opening
weekend
um let's look at the numbers Disney man
they're they're just going after flops
after flops after flaps right now
so Pixar's film Elemental featuring The
Studio's first non-binary character
earned only 29.5 million dollars on its
opening weekend marking the lowest
opening ever for Pixar the film's
underperformance added to Disney's
recent string of controversial decisions
in the entertainment industry including
a subscriber loss on Disney plus and the
elimination of 75 positions at Pixar
Studios the inclusion of elements like
critical race Theory and shows such as
Proud Family louder and louder and
prouder not not louder in crime
a sparked controversy Pixar's a previous
film light year also faced difficulties
at the box office some attributed to
poor reception to the depiction of
same-sex relationships suggesting that
the audience may have been asked too
much Tom is America kind of getting sick
of this or are we still at a point of
Tolerance hey let's be tolerant with
these movies and cartoons I think
America is on the I'm going to give a
summary here and this may get me shot at
but this is the summary I see I look
around America and I see people working
with straight people gay people all
kinds of folks at their offices and
Civic groups PTA at their school and
they're trying to live in harmony and
there's people that have wanted marriage
rights for a long time John Roberts
decision Supreme Court gave them that
and then Along Comes this whole trans
thing and which really is devolved into
the Bud Light Saga the target Saga
School boards things for teaching kids
and there are gay couples that are right
there protesting the same thing because
they don't want their kids taught young
and I think all of that is coming
together saying
damn it we've had about enough of this
and there was no picket lines for Disney
Elemental you know what it was nobody
took their kids to see it nobody reached
into their pocket to pay you know the 20
a ticket for the 3D you know version of
it with the glasses and they said I've
had enough of it and they said I've had
enough of Bud Light and I said I have
enough at Disney's Elemental I live in a
diverse world stop trying to take an
ultra minority of that and get crazy and
I I I really think that the The Tide is
turning and there's also core you know
lesbian and gay couples that are also
tired of it who also want to bring their
kids up certain ways and also don't like
the portrayal uh I think it's and that's
that's my point I want to I'll tell you
one of the best managers I ever had
um you know in my court in the corporate
part of my life one of the best managers
I had you know it was gay and it didn't
matter he was a great guy and a great
leader any any drove in my court now I'm
talking about my corporate existence you
know and you know there's nothing there
and the fact that he was gay or not gay
didn't matter and I think America lives
in that it's like if you're gay or not
gay it it doesn't matter but all the
wokism and all the stuff around trans
and what's going on bud light and now
Disney and others I think more than just
straight America is fed up with it but
on the I but from what we're seeing
though because you you went through the
list with but light in sports and this
and all that it's like they're they're
not stopping though you know I mean
they're they're still being relentless
they're not they're not seeing the do
you think that like what is the ultimate
goal of this push of just this little
little minority group like what's the
what's the end game I think you have a
lot of corporate PR people and CEOs that
are wimps and why can't you walk to the
microphone that says there's been gay
people working on our company for 50
years you know we've got equal medical
programs we've got you know spousal
Arrangements we have all these things
that we've done for regardless of who
you are just come take a job and do a
good job and I where is that CEO and
where are those PR people saying time
out you know we've we've recognized
these things that work Among Us why do
we have to take this other step why do
we have to have tuck friendly kids
swimsuits for age five are you kidding
me yeah is that's over the waterfall
that's where it is and I I think that
there's there's got to be well by Texas
Rangers Texas Rangers have said baseball
is for everybody we have everybody in
our audience and we feel no need to have
a special celebration of anything that
may or may not be on The Fringe
everybody's here at watching Texas
Rangers and everybody's welcome to be
here where's that voice in the rest of
America because the rest of America is
going to say hey that sounds like common
sense and I think common sense is going
to make a comeback and it's been drowned
out this year by these fringes yep it's
funny that the people aren't saying
anything but they're showing it with
their money and they're not showing up
to all these you know I mean all the
events all the movies and everything
it's like the silent the silent majority
is is happening with the money so good
from and hear me now hear me clearly I'm
not against anybody you are who you are
in a nation where the laws and the
freedoms are to be that but when you
step over the edge and you get in the
face of people's kids and you want to
train their kids while they're at school
and they're underage you're no longer
about personal freedom to be who you are
you're diving down in the lives of their
kids and guess what you're pissing
America off yeah you were about to sound
like the Reverend from back in the days
we're not against rap but we are against
rappers but we are against those thugs
thugs but by the way I want to show you
this so Brandon showed me this yesterday
this is a Gallop report that just came
in
fewer in U.S say same-sex relations
morally acceptable interesting this is
the first time it's gone down Tom take a
look at this 64 down
from 71 percent say same-sex relations
are morally acceptable slightly more 60
percent than last year's say death
penalty is morally okay
birth control divorce still most widely
viewed as morally acceptable so and by
the way this is Gallop it's not this is
not Fox this is not CNN this is purely
Gallop if you want to go a little lower
to see the moral issues on where we're
at on on uh how people are looking at
this 22 to 23 birth control uh change is
What minus four percent uh divorce minus
three percent sex between unmarried men
and women minus four percent having a
baby outside of marriage unchanged
gambling minus two gay or lesbian
relations the biggest one minus seven
percent people are like yeah I don't
know if that's morally acceptable that's
Gallop that's saying this medical
research using stem cells uh unchanged
can you zoom in a little bit that death
penalty went up people are supporting
death penalty that went up buying and
wearing clothes made of animal fur oh
that's going to be upsetting certain
people here zero percent doctor assisted
suicide wow I didn't know Hillary is a
doctor
abortion unchanged medical by the way
it's interesting that abortion is
unchanged 50 to 52. medical testing on
animals minus four sex between teenagers
minus three pornography minus two minus
four by the way it's as if America
became more conservative in the last
time you're crazy
it's right what are the numbers that
have the the greatest increase or
decrease if you can scroll back up it's
gay it's it's gay or lesbian minus seven
that's the five there's nothing that's a
greater change than that nothing of
being morally acceptable of not being
morally acceptable they're not open to
it they're less open to it than they
were a year ago this is America but they
went up in the death penalty yeah yeah
they want to kill people What was the
top of the article called right there
American opinion of moral issues oh
there was another article that he that I
think the top the article you recent
about
so with this whole moral stance how do
you process this I'm curious now when
you hear this how do you process this I
I I happen to believe that
when you have an over amplification of
anything in society what happens is
people will be pushed people are pushed
back
um into the corner of their core belief
and I think what we're seeing here is
lawlessness
um from what happened with the BLM riots
it's not about the point of um of Rights
and and and Racial equality in this
country it was how it was executed how
it was pushed back defund the police
makes people feel insecure I think when
you take all those out and you push them
what happens is it's a purification
process of what their core beliefs are
and it doesn't surprise me the survey
would go up I'd like to see the survey
from right now to two years from now
after a new president and when people
have had time to think about a little
bit I'd love to see that
you see did it push back a little bit
and then they kind of come back to where
they were you know what it is I think I
think this could be called the tolerance
index you know how we have the greed of
fear greeted index yeah it needs to be
called the tolerance index because this
is kind of how tolerance Works which
which religion is the most tolerant
religion
Christianity Christianity is the most
tolerant religion I mean you can put
Christianity
um Judaism is pretty tolerant I would
say Judaism and Christianity is but I
would say
God forbid you say something about you
know a Jewish uh uh what do you say uh
wow you know when you think about Jews
and their money and their disasters you
could actually get any criticism
you can say whatever you want about
Christianity you can say whatever you
want about Christianity right so so to
say the most tolerant religion is who
Christianity I think so so the gays have
to thank Christians for being the most
tolerant because the Christians are
sitting there saying hey as long as
you're doing your own thing yeah gay
community LGBT cannot thank the Muslim
Community because the Muslim Community
is not going to be like amen you want to
come out here for us to do XYZ nah it's
not going to happen live your life
privately do whatever you want it's not
going to be a public thing that we're
going to create a pride month for you
yeah and we're going to recognize you I
think Americans are kind of sitting
there saying well you know what this
tolerance thinks maybe there's a limit
for it and you cross the line we we were
tolerant with you now you're abusive and
now you're disrespecting us now you're
insulting us and we're going to pump the
brakes right here yeah that index could
be called the tunnels index do you think
how much do you think is the trans well
like Tom was talking about the trans
movement is is affected at -7 where
people are just like listen we were
totally cool everybody was chilling now
this one little might looks like it's
like having that drunk uncle the trans
movement is like having that drunk uncle
that shows up to the barbecue you're
like we were we were having fun now
you're taking your pants off you're
jumping in the pool you're causing a
fight that how much do you think that
that is reflecting in that minus a
massive massive amount and a massive
amount I don't know anybody that has a
problem with gay people never or look at
nice like nobody's it's been decades and
that's even been an issue in this
country yep the teach resolved too John
Robertson the T stuff the teas are
messing messing at all and the kids
stuff yeah the drag stuff yeah the
grooming stuff yeah correct all of a
sudden it's like I don't know about all
not just awareness of the trans yeah
that's not awareness of a of of a
self-identifying group it's not what it
is it's when they've crossed over into
their family into people for sure in the
education indoctrination and Conformity
yeah not you and everybody else is
saying wait wait wait wait get off my
lawn yeah and and I and I hate how they
they turn it to like we're us talking
like this this right now people are like
they're transphobic no no no no no I'm
not phobic I'm not afraid of spot like
trick like it's like arachnophobe I'm
not scared of you nobody's scared of
[__] it's just listen we feel you you're
going through some you know uh mental
stuff and I hope that you can get better
and everything but pushing it down our
throats pushing it down our kids throats
and then like I said doing all those
shows where you're just butt naked in
front of kids what what is what how is
that furthering your phobic means fear
right yeah I'm not scared of anything
yeah I am not transphobic I am not
afraid of you you want to meet at the
school board and you want to try to
force education on kids there are people
that are not transphobic they are not
afraid of you and they will meet you on
the steps of the courthouse and they
will hit you in the mouth to show they
are not afraid yeah exactly it's not
about being transphobic it's like it's
like trans hey I've always felt this way
and so I cross-dress and this is what it
is and I'm trans okay
there's that but then and I think I
should go to the school board and I
think there should be books it should be
this and this and this and this and say
wait wait we just went from you
identifying yourself as trans and some
things are to now crossing over and you
want to indoctrinate Nate my kids my
wait wait wait wait there's the line
that's the line and that's what's going
on and you know that's where they want
to say oh you're transphobic I'm no
they're not transphobic they're pissed
off at you there's a big difference you
know MLK famously said Don't Judge Me by
the color of my skin but the content of
my character what if my question is
like I don't ever introduce myself and
be like hey Pat I'm a heterosexual man I
like having sex with women my preferred
uh positions are doggy style and like
that's never my lead story okay but I
grew up Jewish in Miami I was an athlete
in high school nobody does that that's
not how it works but when you they throw
that out first of like this is how I
sexually identify this was what my
sexual proclivity is and this is how you
need to accept me it's like bro I just
want you to get the job done yeah and
it's like that's the lead story and
nobody cares to tell you though you did
that so naturally like I wonder if
that's how you [__] with girls at bars
hey Mary I'm Andy Adam this I'm straight
I'm the header for this yeah yeah are
you open to leaving the club right now
or the bar right now that seemed a
little too natural it's like a script
yeah listen yeah you know practice makes
perfect my name is Adam 16 of the men in
this bar is straight I'm one of them
wow I like that wow
if a shirt started trending it says I'm
straight
yeah he just started selling the shirt
says I'm straight oh my God and people
are looking at us me too yeah you too
straight like instead of a pride month
like it's it's okay
like hey guys I'm sorry but you know
what I like women but it's interesting
that we're having this conversation on
pride month have you seen what Elon Musk
has been slowly dripping out there no
what the flag what do you do with the
LGBT that was hilarious he'll be like Oh
I'm sorry but what what country is this
flag from what what yeah where'd it come
from where are these people from like
Elon Musk is slowly he's a funny red
pill he's a troll but he is not a fan of
the rainbow Mafia trans for sure
yeah what do you think it is what are
you we've been studying Elon Adam why do
you think he's doing this I think you
know Common Sense prevails and it's just
becoming complete overreach and you know
how many people from that Community from
the far far left
of that community
have been calling for his head there's
so many people that hate Elon Musk now
oh my God because he is an entrepreneur
he's made his billions he's a capitalist
he's a defender of free speech and you
know he's an easy target and he's not
falling in line and he's a free thinker
and it's it's interesting to see the
pushback that he's getting right there
but he's a very very necessary voice in
the world dude he put his he put his
money where his mouth is so we could
have our speech and I respect the hell
out of him you just traveled you were in
Romania then you went to Israel yeah
um I don't want to get yelled at for
mentioning your vacation plans but it's
like you went around and you're at some
places there what did you see out there
when you compare what's happening in
American cities with you know woke
demonstrations things are going on
compared to where just last week you
were yeah the well it was actually
pretty interesting because um I was in
Jerusalem one of the most holiest places
on the planet you just want to talk
traditional conservative holy religious
cities
I didn't see one pride flag in Jerusalem
but in Tel Aviv my friend forget it oh
man it was everywhere really and
everywhere in Tel Aviv Tel Aviv very
liberal State Tel Aviv is a big party
Tel Aviv is South Beach partying going
out Beach nightlife and they just had
their their pri I mean they're a very
proud country I mean most countries are
proud there's a lot of Israeli Flags
Star of David of course I when I tell
you there were more Pride Flags in Tel
Aviv really than there were
their nation's flag I was shocked like
you want to have a pride fight that's
cool but to have it everywhere was was
quite shocking
like shabbat shalom did you get any of
those guys
I don't even know I think my goodness
I'm a Chevette thing attention editors
that's an emergency short clip
oh my God like like hold on were there
like yamakas with like the flag and
stuff on them I mean they were it was
recently just Flags they were everywhere
I saw one sign I saw one sign that says
uh well you know shout out to you for
your for your pride but you can thank a
straight person for your existence
straight Pride oh it's pretty good
listen I I think nobody again it sounds
like we're we're a gay bashing it's not
oh we can't make fun of it I make fun of
everybody as a comedian as a former
comedian you know it's not racist if you
make fun of everybody yeah if you can
get it and you can get it and you can
get it you can get it I'll make fun of
Jews and Muslims and Christians and gays
and blacks and white Asians it's like
you guys can get it too if you actually
want to be accepted you got to take the
good with the best oh dude you should
see Pat just the trend sketch we did
where I it's on valuetainment Comedy
where I um I'm trans everything I'm
translate I'm transparent it's it's a
common skin in the comments some guy's
like this is disgusting and I well I
never really respond I went into I go
who what you think your little group is
off limits I go I make fun of myself
Middle Easterns black white tall short
gay I don't care your group you ain't
off limits dawg I'm going after you too
it's not it's in good taste I'm not
saying any any people that hurt them or
doing this but it's like bro you're not
off limits and I will make fun of your
ass so nobody should be here
heterosexuals stopping Extinction for
five thousand years and it's just like
you gotta be able to use a sense of
humor so like there's a lot of people
right now let's just pick on me and the
Jews for a second yeah I can't believe
Vinnie who's not Jewish just made fun of
Adam oh my God he made fun of the gay
community in the Jewish community and
the gay Jewish Community all in one like
and as a Jew I'm like that's actually
[__] hilarious if the Jewish guy's
laughing stop being so butt hurt
and speaking of butt hurt
[Laughter]
all right let's go to the next one here
we need to channel
oh all right so we got their role isn't
to educate Society Kevin O'Leary just
ripped Mark Cuban's claim that going
woke is good for business warns that you
risk alienating 50 of your customers uh
so these are two you know two of the
guys probably the main guys on the great
uh Shark Tank show
that's out there uh duking it out here
let me go to the store here so here we
go
Mark Cuban believes embracing woke
ideology is good for business but Kevin
O'Leary disagrees stating when you get
involved in partisan issues you
basically lose 50 of your constituency
why you don't why you would uh do that
when you're a cust consumer goods or
Service Company everybody is learning
makes absolutely no sense olira
emphasizes that the role of a
corporation is to serve its customers
employees and shareholders and not to
educate Society on social issues he
States their role is not to educate
Society on the social issue of the day
companies like Anheuser-Busch inbev and
Target have faced negative consequences
for allegedly going to walk O'Leary
points out when you lose 9 10 11 12
billion dollars a market cap you know
that you've offended somebody and that
that person is your customer that's bad
business really bad business Tom
uh well first of all Kevin O'Leary comes
up out from under the rock after FTX
says he's been sitting oh yeah oh yeah
it's a heavy Rock and then and then it's
like hey something to talk about that
that's not three letters
um I think there's some truth to kept
what Kevin O'Leary is saying Kevin
O'Leary is saying hey you you look at
it's kind of what I just said there are
a number of people that like our
products we're not going to be for or
against any one of them please enjoy
um and I think Kevin O'Leary is
absolutely correct
um and I think he points out if you're
upsetting a customer what are you doing
now that's different from if you're that
you just saw a thing about fur coats
you're making fur coats and the animal
activists aren't going to be happy with
you or you're tobacco and no one's happy
about the addictive uh that Vape is so
addictive and now you're getting
teenagers involved this isn't that this
is Kevin O'Leary saying hey if these are
your customers why would you why would
you upset any of your customers forget
that this is about woke that's the
question O'Leary's asking why would you
upset any of your customers and I think
he's dead right but here's my sorry what
what is up with Mark Cuban he is he that
left Pat where he's like vaccine and
everybody get this and he's he's getting
involved and he's all this works like
what what is what is his deal what what
is up with this guy no no no Mark Cuban
don't let him fool you he's one of the
sharpest cats out there he knows he
knows exactly what he's doing who he's
supporting
um he he's the type of guy
that he is a sequencing guy like he
knows I'm gonna support this guy because
I'm gonna get this guy and I'm gonna
defend this guy and I'm going to be
against he knows like he he the enemies
he's chosen you know who he's defending
who's who's that he's a part of he's
he's not a dummy Mark Cuban knows what
he's doing so whether it's it's knowing
the fact that if you don't go woke what
is the benefit of he if he fuels the
Dallas Maps can you can you go to the
Dallas Maps valuation what is a big
chunk of his net worth is with the mask
he bought it I think for 240 million
bucks
I believe his non-sports his non-sports
uh net worth pad I think is 1.1 to be
exactly so he's worth five billion yeah
his non-sport is 1.1 well I mean his
ground sport is probably a little bit
more than that but the team is a 3.3
billion is not worth it might not even
be five billion it's 5.1 okay that's
what it is a Mark Cuban net worth I want
to say it's four point yeah 5.1 billion
okay so 5.1 Billion Auto Network that
marks God so so
what happens if all of a sudden NBA
Brokers a deal with China
you know what happens to that 3.3
billion dollars it's going up did you
see when the Denver Broncos were all of
a sudden bought for whatever and do you
remember who made everybody in the NBA
Rich who's the most hated owner in the
NBA that met everybody rich in the NBA
World Donald
the LA Clippers for what did he sell uh
2.1 billion what was that like Clipper
service two billion and change too
billion dollars I thought it was a
little over 2 billion okay two billion
dollars okay do me a favor type how much
did Donald Sterling buy the clippers for
because it was a San Diego Clippers when
he bought it yeah
85 San Diego Clippers yeah it's okay 12
and a half million oh my god the guy
buys the Clippers for 12 and a half
million sells it for 2 billion you know
what x that is he had bills with 120
million 100 X's 1.25 he sells it for
nearly 180x of what he paid for it right
when Donald Sterling did that everybody
went like this I hate the guy but damn I
love the guy you know he just made me a
billionaire dog yeah okay so the next
Crazy Event like this that can get the
NBA to be insane valuations is if they
go into China and if you know if if Adam
Silver wants to be known as a
commissioner like the great Robert Kraft
that made all NFL owners billionaires
where NFL owners like you can fly
private jet for the rest of your life
and your great great great great
grandkids will give you best health
insurance for the rest of your life your
entire family you can go anywhere that's
pretty much a deal he got plus 25
million I don't know what the deal was
37 million or some salary
he knows if he pisses off the wrong
people Mark Cuban that sequencing of
getting that contract in China again I'm
speculating I don't know this is purely
opinions here but the guy's not a dummy
he's choosing sides and he knows which
side he's not a part of and for you to
go and like be against a musk or a Rogan
really like what what do you mean like
do you know who likes musk do you know
who likes broken you know what kind of
people like those two guys your audience
question authority it's people that are
anti-establishment it people that are
ballsy it's people that can stand up for
something it's people that are willing
to say some stuff that is gonna offend
the doctors that you can't ever offend
those people you're offending the people
that are already protected and you're
putting like this yeah that that no one
respects that people respect what the
rogans and the musks are doing people
respect those types of people and I
don't know by the way he's like I said I
would love to see Mark go into the
presidential debate you know why I'd
love to see that you know I'd love to
see that because I'd love to see a true
debate where he goes boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom on tennis shoes not a
debate where it's boom boom and it's
like you move on a certain tweet you
call somebody I do move on yeah you get
quiet and often hide and I will tell you
the credit to Mark Mark will have a
debate with somebody on Twitter and
it'll be a 20 part debate so he's not
somebody that backs off and moves on so
I'd love to see the guy run I think uh
he actually has a shot at becoming a
president I think he cannot he has a
shot of being a president as a
Democratic party of course he won't run
as a republican speaking of selling your
NBA team what Jordan just sold the
Charlotte Hornets for three billion
dollars something like that he bought it
for 275 million another one right there
10 years ago and by the way what you're
saying with China in the NBA
sounds far-fetched it's not why would
the NBA ever do something like that what
do you mean yeah we have a recent case
example
with the PGA and live
right two years ago and never in a
million years that we think that Saudi
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia would own
part of the PGA yeah and we've seen this
kind of play out and they've partnered
up and they've done everything that but
yeah PGA Tour agrees to merge with
saudi-backed rival live golf and we and
I think it was Greg Norman who basically
I think led the charge from Saudi that's
correct the Saudis recruited Greg to be
their president so very interesting just
when you think like why would the NBA
ever do it's like all right well we've
got something here a little fun fact
about the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia you
know that we say that Russia is not a
country it's just a it's just a gas
station masquerading as a country even
more so in Saudi but uh the prince NBS
Mohamed balsaman
um I think he developed a plan a handful
of years ago or basically said we're too
reliant on oil and the way that we need
to diversify our country's resources is
to start buying sports teams and sports
leagues and franchises and they've
brought I mean what soccer teams
massive I mean if you if you look at you
know the story Miami messy what did they
try to do exactly they think to buy them
for like a billion bucks a year whatever
something crazy Saudi Arabia has bought
into soccer and golf well the NBA and
NFL be next they've had a mandate in
Saudi Arabia
don't just be a hundred percent reliant
on what Saudi aramco I think that's the
third largest
country uh Company by market cap in the
world do you think you have uh Apple
um
at number one three trillion dollars I
want to say uh what's number two help me
out here Tom you're you're this is like
number four Forbes 400 yeah exactly
whatever but Saudi aramco is number
three I know they're worth two trillion
dollars or then some uh it might be
Microsoft whatever
um
speaking of market cap yeah but they're
basically saying our entire country or
entire economy is basically relying on
Saudi aramco government owned oil
company and the way that they want to
diversify their investment strategy is
buy sports teams Galore that's how they
end up buying live I mean it's not going
to be close to the kind of money they
have but but I get the fact that they
diverse they're diversifying and
imposing their influence in different
sports and yesterday I was looking at
the the comparison about
China and India Brandon Kelly and I were
sitting there talking about China and
India and uh how China started taking uh
uh a foreign direct investments in 1990
and it skyrocketed them into where they
are today India didn't start taking
foreign investments until 2005.
and so India's behind China around 10
years like just 10 years ago only 70
percent of Indians had full-on
electricity China 100 had electricity
today I think India is at 98 or
something like that they're at a higher
number than they were before of course
India's Got a younger population than
China by 12 years I think India is like
26 China's 38. but here they come but
but the one yeah they're definitely
going to come and they're investing into
education uh when it comes down to
Railways they have more uh because I
think China is three times the size of
India but China only has twice the
amount of Railways as India does and
ports wise China's got way more than
China than India anyways but the point
was them them allowing outside people to
invest into their country okay China had
the 51 rule like if you're going to do
anything in India you know in China
you've got to control 51 percent of it
49 all that stuff they kind of have that
process that they did uh you know in
America's typically been protected uh so
there is there should be a little bit of
threat when other other people want to
invest too much into your country
because they're having influence over it
as well so I don't know how people are
going to feel about Saudi making those
types of Investments aggressively you
can't really prevent it it's not like
it's a 51 number but that is something
you ought to think about long term is it
going to be a good thing or a bad thing
so if if 20 years from now 50 of MBA
teams are owned by Saudi owners is that
a good thing I don't know about that so
these are things that that one has to
consider go ahead Tom yeah you know
what's interesting is you look through
history Pat's making a great point in
the 1990s
commercial real estate and residential
real estate
um in California Hawaii were being
inundated by whose money
this is what year 90s late 80s Japanese
correct and Japanese look at me for 500
Japanese we're buying very large things
in America like Manhattan soil like they
uh I think I believe
um Japanese I may be wrong but I thought
a Japanese Company still owns
Rockefeller Center and all the the stuff
around it and actually it's leased back
to GE and NBC and all that became but
everybody back then was like oh my gosh
they're going to dominate World
semiconductor they're already look what
they're doing with um with you know
Lexus and Acura and Nissan and infinity
here they come they're going to destroy
our Auto industry they're going to do
this and they're an ally they're part of
G7 and everybody was freaked out by it
but they're cycles that happen with with
The Wealth of Nations and their
currencies being trading above other
people and they overcooked it which led
to what they call the Lost decade where
their their economy crashed and if you
read about Japan you can read about the
Lost decade so there's cycles that go
right now and right now we are in a
Saudi cycle and the Saudi side 90s I
just think we have to be a little bit of
Sports organization not Sports
organizations but leagues
um if if there is already something in
place where you can't like a [__] is
there can you can you type something Rob
to see what what is the the rules about
International
investors buying
sports teams in Americas their rule
against that like what they can and
can't do because Americans have been
buying soccer you know Stan cronke owns
Manchester United doesn't he the owner
is it is it look are the nuggets as much
money as we have in America you don't
have Saudi type of money there's not
guys that have that kind of money now
don't get me wrong there's some people
say well the richest guys this guy or
that guy or this guy we have money but
if Saudis using oil money to pick up
five billion dollar sports teams what
the hell is that to them that's chump
change infinite oil but below your feet
is a crazy ATM yeah I can take 100
billion and buy 20 I can buy 100 billion
and buy 33 3 billion dollar teams I can
literally buy 33 3 billion dollar teams
that's pretty much the NBA that's the
whole NBA because some of the teams are
worth 1.2 billion some of them are worth
4.5 billion I can buy the entire MBA 400
billion dollars I read a joke Pat about
you hear that like it's 30 teams crazy
if each team is worth three billion
dollars on average I can buy the entire
NBA team every one of them for 100
billion Elon Musk could buy every single
NBA team
oh my God I didn't think about having a
question yeah yeah that'd be nuts I
heard a joke made about the Saudis it
says it's not about dollars it's about
days
so what do you mean it says well um I
want to buy I want to buy the Dallas
Cowboys what is that 6 billion okay
that's uh how many days do we do we pump
it's basically they're talking about how
many days that makes sense the oil out
of the ground that makes sense I can buy
that I can buy the uh every 21 days I
could buy the Dallas Cowboys yep that's
crazy yep so would you say about that
Saudi has the most out of every they're
just the richest I don't know I mean
some say Saudi some say Putin is the
richest guy in the world some say
certain you know certain people in in in
China that low-key no one like
specifically she not everybody because
people are leaving China billionaires
and millionaires are leaving China yeah
a hardcore right now uh so what is that
NFL rules prohibit foreign investments
and franchise but rules were made to be
disregarded when sufficiently profitable
to do so Tuesday's stunning news that
the PGA okay so interesting so in the
NFL so yes the public investment fund
the formal name of the Sovereign wealth
fund of Saudi Arabia can get into the
NFL if it wants and if it has to set up
a competing League to light the fuse so
be it it worked in golf why wouldn't it
work in football man if these guys
create a competing team and they go to
guys like Joe burrow and Josh Allen say
we'll pay you a hundred million dollars
a year wow to come by we will give you a
10 year billion dollar contract all gone
and makes it you know they recruit the
50 best players in the NFL that go over
there it's over yeah that's it's a wrap
do you know what I would do what's that
I'm gonna say something here watch this
so let's I'm now
Prince Thomas of Saudi Arabia hi Prince
and I create an organization over here
and I start doing nil of everybody
that's going to be the top drop picks
Pat and I start stealing your draft
picks because what I do I go into
college and I can outbid you on nil
which is exactly what they did with Phil
Mickelson and with um uh Bryson Shambo
and top-line golfers that they paid
those incredible join fees remember
those Mixels was rumored to have gotten
500 million dollars to join live so what
if they go over here very legally and
create a fund and go after nil of NBA
players and uh NFL players at the
Collegiate level yeah and nil for those
that don't remember its name image and
likeness right the new legal way to get
sponsorship dollars to athletes what if
they do high school athletes the college
athletes which have been forbidden for
yeah forever if I'm legally that's
saying that they can do that right
Prince Thomas I could do that tomorrow
morning if I had the money and
completely disrupt I could have the top
draft picks if I had a feeder system
into a pro league
this is giving me very uh Coming to
America Vibes like he's a prince
he's got his own money baby he got his
own money well I'm just outlining how
easy it would be to do could you see
that happening Pat I can they just did
it in golf everybody was hating I can't
believe you're doing this I can't
believe you're doing that well living
PGA have decided to team up together
yeah yeah what happened Phil Mickelson
you betrayed by the way you know 500
million by the way you know Greg Norman
was a guy that was hated you know Greg
Norman had no idea this was happening
this happened behind his back he had no
clue when this was announced he says I
have no I was not a part of this no one
told me this was happening I just heard
the news myself yeah the top CEOs in her
board there was five people that got
together they were trying to settle the
suits and they said but what made the
settle is maybe we just pumped the money
in the PGA and we own it Jay Monahan was
like that'd be really hypocritical in me
you could be President James will pay
you 20 million dollars but you know I
think it could be a we could figure it
out that's hilarious and what's 20
million to these guys it's like minimum
wage 15 bucks an hour for them okay all
right by the way once again and what is
the most money that disappeared out of
your hands folks like like
has any have you ever overpaid on a
check and by how much okay because
here's what the Pentagon accountant just
did somebody needs to fight a pentagon
account Pentagon accounting error
provides an extra
0.2 billion dollars for Ukraine military
aid this is an ABC story okay this is
this is an ABC story so let's see what
ABC has to say just a couple about this
a little mistake I mean it's just too
professional teams
here we go Pentagon has admitted to a
6.2 billion dollar accounting gear and
the value of weapons by the way do you
have the video rap of the lady saying it
the way she just said it very casually
sent to Ukraine over the past two years
the mistake was due to using replacement
costs instead of Book value this Surplus
will be used for uh future security
packages uh the surplus funds
will be utilized to support Ukraine and
it's counter-offensive against Russia
Ukraine air defenses successfully uh uh
down 32 out of 35 Russian drones the use
the U.S has provided less than 34
billion dollars in a to Ukraine contrary
to previous estimates of 40 billion
President Biden has pledged ongoing
support but concerns about costs and
duration of the conflict persists the
accounting mistake will not impact Aid
delivery here's a lady if you want to
play this club wow
following up from some announcements
earlier this year during the
Department's regular oversight of our
execution of presidential drawdown
Authority for Ukraine we discovered
inconsistencies in equipment valuation
for Ukraine in a significant number of
cases Services used replacement costs
rather than net Book value thereby
overestimating the value of the
equipment drawn down from U.S stocks and
provided to Ukraine once we discovered
this misvaluation the Comptroller
reissued guidance on March 31st
clarifying how to Value equipment in
line
with the financial management regulation
and DOD policy to ensure we use the most
accurate of accounting methods we have
confirmed that for FY 23 the final
calculation is 3.6 billion dollars and
for FY 22 it is 2.6 billion for a
combined total of 6.2 billion dollars
these valuation errors in no way limit
or restricted the size of any of our
pdas or impacted the provision of
support to Ukraine and while the dod
while the dod retains the authority to
utilize the recaptured PDA this has no
bearing on appropriated usai or Ukraine
PDA replenishment funding approved by
Tom and then people wonder why we are so
much in debt we don't even know how to
for those of you day Traders pick up
pick up an index on defense contractors
because 6.2 billion dollars is heading
out the door to buy more stuff going to
the Ukraine yeah that's insane man that
is how do they make a blunder like that
how do you mess how do you how do you
mess that up I was in first grade and
they told me always carry the one
6.2 bill don't be so hard on those guys
it's a mistake people make mistakes like
that and they overpay on the bill that's
a pretty big couch that's 6.2 billion
dollars
and it's going for a good cause we're
gonna give it to him in the future
anyways yeah so we might as well listen
let's not judge Perfection from our
government employees let's only expect
Perfection from us yeah if we make
mistakes like that I apologize we could
get fired and go to jail but if you make
mistakes like then the government should
get a promotion it's like a it's you
should recognize this type of behavior
for people to want to make those
um I don't know I just think it's you
know it's it's Lawyers Guns and Money
I'm actually
happy that this happened why for two
reasons
um number one so we can talk about stuff
like this it's like hold on this is
what's happening guys all right question
you know I've said uh vocally I think we
should have some involvement in what's
going on there but there should be some
limitations to the money aspect of it
okay and this is just one of those
situations where it's like all right
guys
you know we support I get it you know
country just can't invade countries we
can't just sit along the sidelines and
say nothing and do nothing but they're
doing there does need to be some
limitations to how much money we're
going to be investing and funding this
operation and here's a situation where
we can point to and say oh say good
night to the bad guy there's the bad guy
like all right what's going on here guys
yeah because and they'll spin it they'll
say well you know we were actually
planning on spend sending this in 30
days from now so now 30 days from now
accounts receivable we'll just backtrack
we'll just deduct that from the
accounting premise of uh they'll spin it
but there does need to be some
limitations on how much we're spending
here so this is not a freaking
Afghanistan situation where we've been
end up giving trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars and having
nothing to show for well you know what
that's 6.2 billion dollars would have
done to just to help Americans just give
like just to hand out some of that money
or or help some veterans or help help
help some homeless 6.2 billion as and
it's just the whoops that's all all that
is is a whoops for almost for 6.2
billion dollars bro that's embarrassing
and like you said I have nothing
nothing's gonna happen they're just like
hey at least it's going to a good cause
every Thursday thousands
stray dogs are put to death
for fifteen dollars
but we are living in a time where a
number that starts with a B it's not
even a isn't that big of a deal
starts with the T homie yeah not that
kind of team
trillion I'm not shot Transformers
hello let's talk about let's talk about
how did we go back to this I'm gonna go
away at this point Mark Zuckerberg musk
let's first talk about the master plan
and we'll talk about the fight yes and
we're not going to talk about Elon
musk's parody account
Mark Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg
Zuckerberg's master plan to kill off
Twitter revealed meta to launch rival
character limited app condemned project
92 in comic months this is tapping up
taping up Oprah Winfrey and the Dalai
Lama to attract users oh my god wow
coming to a city near you type of stuff
right Mark work is not happy with what
uh uh uh what's his name's getting uh
musk is getting and it's a little too
much attention but let's see what
happens here we like competition this is
America
so Mark Zuckerberg is reportedly
planning to launch a rival Twitter
platform uh to go up against these guys
have expressed interest in joining the
new platform Dalai Lama and Oprah
Winfrey which aimed to provide a
trustworthy alternative to Twitter the
new app potentially named threads will
resemble Twitter in terms of its
continuous
scroll to text and like and retweet
functions it will also adopt a 500
character limit proposed closer to
Twitter origin 180 character limit meta
aims to create an app that prioritizes
safety east of use and reliability
Meadows project 92 plans to integrate
the with Instagram's account systems and
other decentralized platforms like
Maston Don Tom what do you know about
this story here uh first of all let's
let's go into history name
one product that Mark has made you know
billion dollar market cap successful
Facebook Facebook
Instagram oh wait he bought it WhatsApp
oh wait he bought it detect a trend here
Facebook has not deployed anything
except meta and it's as it's known has
not deployed anything except Facebook in
its original form plus the extension
features that are on Facebook they
haven't been successful meta is a
smoking Crater of stock dividends that
are unpaid it's a smoking crater it's
it's become nothing and how many
headlines do we see hey Mark when do you
give up on that haven't we seen these
headlines there's a lot of money you're
spending you keep spending are you going
to back off this thing maybe and go to
dividends what he's trying to do here
So Meta is going to make a Facebook
clone and get open the Dalai Lama to
cause a big you know migration of people
over there no no Twitter's at scale
Twitter is refining itself Twitter is is
doing the right things and Facebook has
zero track record of building anything
on its own successfully exhibit a meta
I mean when you say that way and the
question becomes how many people have
tried to build a Twitter right now and
is there a climate for somebody to build
a Twitter against Elon musk's Twitter
are they going to be able to compete
against Elon musk's Twitter people don't
realize that behind closed doors I
wonder what other things elon's building
within Twitter I'm sure they're about to
launch an Ott I'm sure they're about to
pay their talent very well I'm sure if
they if they talk across and decided to
put a show on Twitter there's stuff that
Tucker knows that we don't know about
about what future compensation
structures are coming I'm not saying
there's a side deal I'm not saying Elon
is paying them but I am saying there may
be a little bit more until that Tucker
has to take his talent to Twitter than
anywhere else maybe because they're
about to launch something who knows but
this is not a guy that's sitting on his
Laurels just like hey I'm gonna be okay
doing this I'm going to be doing that
now here's the part
if you look at Musk he's not in the best
shape okay no because musk has got so
much time in the best in the companies
he's building I'm not saying he's in bad
shape he's lost a lot of weight he's
looking better but he's not in best
shape now Zuck is an incredible [__]
because he's not that focused on
creating the next thing he's just buying
stuff but he's got a lot of time
practice in Jiu Jitsu and he's actually
looking really good right and training
in videos and all the stuff that's
coming out so the story that's going
that's a bit viral right now
is Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg agree
to hold cage fight and this is a BBC
story can we know BBC tells the truth
always yeah so here's the story from BBC
shout out to Luke about what's going on
over there uh with BBC so Tech
billionaires Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg have agreed to kh5 with
musk's uh stating on Twitter I'm up for
a cage fight Zuckerberg responded by
saying send me location musk proposed
holding the fight in the Octagon in Las
Vegas the arena use for UFC battles he
added humorously I have this great move
that I call the walrus but I just lie on
top of my opponent and do nothing
that is hilarious
The Exchange gained viral attention
sparking debates and memes among social
media users in related news meta the
parent company of Facebook and Instagram
is reportedly developing a text-based
social network to rival Twitter
potentially challenging musk Twitter
presence let me ask you good luck now
what are the chances of these guys doing
a cage fight give me give me the give me
the zero two hundred what's the chances
I think Elon would do it and I don't
think Zuckerberg would ever show up
something what do you mean Zuckerberg's
the one that's training and he dude he
just joined a tournament Pat where he
wore a mask he bored the skies that's
the actual let me ask you something and
this PR word came out and said no no he
didn't concede he didn't concede because
last time you actually saw Mark
Zuckerberg not in front of Congress or
being like doing some cyborg takeover he
does podcasts with Joe he does podcasts
with Friedman he's Zuckerberg's done his
podcast with Joe Rogan Zuckerberg's been
on Rogan and Zuckerberg's been on Lex
twice I don't think I think Zuck is
trying to Rebrand himself he should one
step at a time I think Zuck is trying to
Rebrand himself and we'll see obviously
what's gonna happen there with these
guys but I don't know if they're going
to do it or not and quite frankly I got
to tell you you know I don't know if
musk should do it I think Zuck will do
it okay if they fight well can I can I
give you a little tail of the tape here
we go real quick yeah I'm just you know
we were down at UFC
on our courtesy of Joe Rogan yeah Israel
out of Sonya fight Trump walked in crazy
insane but just picture this all right
go with me for a second here guys Bruce
Buffer right now you know that whole
thing that he does
come to the coming to the octagon
the Challenger okay the man that owns
Tesla the man that owns Twitter the man
that owns SpaceX yeah he's been out
there weighing in at 200 pounds standing
six foot two tall
52 years old hailing from South Africa
now currently living on Mars 225 baby
okay Elon
the what the walrus musk
six two two hundred six two two one
knowing him he would walk up with a
walrus yeah
how old do you think zuckers five nine
yeah five ten
clocking in at 160 pounds with a height
of five seven oh yeah look at look at
this man look I don't know five seven 39
years old
born and raised in a secret lab cyborgs
facility somewhere and the metaverse
guys I don't know what you're saying I
think this guy looks good we can say
whatever we want Zach is looking good to
me those kicks are not easy Elon Musk is
going to whoop his ass if Elon lays on
top of him he looks bigger when your
opponent is five five Elon gets on top
of him it's over no you
anyway you're underestimating the power
of you know doing Jiu Jitsu I listen
here's how this thing works Elon is
running three freaking companies I'm not
even naming the other smaller ones he's
running boring company he's running
SpaceX he's running Tesla he has a solar
deal he's doing all this other stuff
that he's doing and you want and he's
doing more interviews he's talking to
people left and right he's doing media
the guy probably sleeps four to six
hours a night I think Zuck is probably
sleeping eight hours per night you're
missing the big Point here he's just
gonna plug in a neural link Bruce Lee
chip boom and all of a sudden he's gonna
know every single karate move out there
it's like the Matrix
maybe maybe I'm just spiteful because
Zuck took me down from Instagram by the
way shout out to Oscar from evolve uh
digital for getting my uh
yeah okay but so maybe I'm just spiteful
um but hardcore Elon Musk can we talk
about the submarine situation here
what's going going on so first of all
missing Titanic submarine updates fears
grow for Titan crew as Oxygen Supply
runs out but rescue bit continues this
is a sun story from today the missing
Titanic submarine named Titan is feared
to have run out of oxygen raising
concerns for the cruise survival The
Vessel disappeared during a Voyage to
the Titanic shipwreck of the coast of
Canada approximately 435 miles south of
St John's Newfoundland the Ocean Gate
Expedition sub uh submersible measuring
6.7 meters 22 feet long carried a 96
hour oxygen supply on board with British
billionaire Adventure harness Harding
uk-based businessman
and his son Suleiman or Ocean Gate I was
about to do Ocean Gate
and French suburbs so what does it say
submersible pilot Paul Henry
their goal at the International Rescue
offer effort has intensified in such a
way where the RAF USAF dispatching a
specialist Ultra deep some anyways
they're trying to get to these guys d8
but it's not succeeding right the U.S
Coast Guard confirms the develop
deployment of the French remotely
operated vehicle Victor 6000 to Aid the
search they're gone so what do you know
about the stories I know this Pat that
their oxygen ran out and God if they are
they have passed God Rest our soul seven
o'clock this morning uh Eastern Standard
Time that was it they're they're if it
ran out it's not it that's all the time
if they haven't surfaced there's no more
oxygen in that little thing and
apparently it was only big enough for
one person to stretch out at a time the
one thing that jumped out for me is the
Stockton Rush the CEO of of that company
uh operating the the Titanic thing he
goes he didn't want to hire 50 year old
white guys and this goes back to all
that people trying to be diverse and
whatever he said when I started this
business one of the things you'll find
from other sub operators uh yeah out
there is uh there typically are people
who are ex-military submariners and
you'll see a whole bunch of 50 year old
white guys I wanted our team to be
younger and inspirational he goes I'm
not gonna inspire a 16 year old to go
pursue Marine technology but a 25 year
old subpilot or a platform operator will
be one of those techs that can be
inspirational and this is one of those
things Pat when it comes to like use
United Airlines I don't I don't want to
be like you know what just because of
diversity requirements I want this type
of person or a female the best person at
the job I want to have again mind you
Pat you know they had a 35 year old like
uh 35 Xbox controller on this thing
that's one thing number two you're a
billionaires what do you just have
nothing else to do what what are two
billionaires going on a little can and
going to see the Titanic wreckage go
watch the movie Titanic go watch a
documentary do you have to go down there
and look at it what's your obsession
what it pat you're you have a couple of
dollars or are you going in a submarine
a baby submarine and going down with
your kid to go look at that right you
have to listen I will tell you I know
people that are very interested in space
and they want to go out in space and see
what's out there I know people that are
more interested in going under and see
what's down there whether it's you know
my son Tico wants to know if there's a
Megalodon he thinks a Megalodon exists
and he thinks aliens exist right I
respect them and that's great and by the
way there are some people that are
didn't James Cameron go to the lowest
point of the ocean uh when he was doing
five thousand something what was that
Marianas Trench in the Pacific two other
people did that where we went all the
way down these are these are guys that
challenge are deep yeah these are guys
that like stuff like this and by the way
here's what's crazy we have to respect
these guys because they're trendsetters
they're not doing this you're not James
Cameron going down there saying 100
we're gonna make it no you're going to
understand [__] we may not make it when
we come back right it's not for
everybody when I was in the Army one of
the things we had to do and I'm sure you
remember this year there was this River
and they had built this tube like this
okay to go under the river because
you're gonna have to do this when you're
in war he says okay you got to go
through this was like 50 yards to go in
there and when you're low crawling and
I'm a big guy man like if you've ever
had an MRI no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no yeah and yeah
I mean there's two my shoulders are
touching and you're in there for like 45
minutes if you have any slight Touch of
claustrophobic and you're in the middle
and you feel stuck do you know what that
does oh my god do you know what that
does to you when you're in the middle
you're like I can't move I can't move I
mean you're trying to get out and you
panic right of course so so this isn't
for everybody you know that's you this
isn't something to do but
um
you know look you know whether a miracle
happens here or not or it's done done
we're gonna find that here in the next
couple whatever but one point you make
that's very valid when it comes down to
hiring jobs like this this is where the
Dei score no one should care about when
it comes down to Military and security
no one should look at the I score when
it comes on to protection of your family
no one should look at the I scores when
it comes down to Flying and I'm trusting
to fly a pilot no one should be looking
at the EI scores when it comes down to
anything that has to do where my safety
your safety or Family Safety is on the
line the last thing you should be
thinking about is Dias shouldn't be
looked at anything but especially in the
area of Safety and Security and they
dropped the ball here so you know is
there going to be conspiracies do you
know who's on there do you know that
what the guy had access to yeah he was
he had a patent that he was about to
launch yeah I mean you know that there's
that part of it as well yeah but uh you
know like the shot the the guy
he's a he's a he's a Pakistani
billionaire he was speaking at the I
think he's in the world economic Forum
he was and that's already people are
like oh here we go he's that guy in his
son but it's like I I mean God rests our
souls if they pass but I mean that's
just uh they've been down there knowing
they're going to die for 90 hours
banging on the whole and hoping to God
that somebody comes and save them but I
think you said it yesterday that's what
happened if that's what happens yeah or
yeah or it imploded but Tom you said it
their search radius is the size of
Connecticut you know what that means
you're not getting found but but then
you think about it pat like besides the
the hiring of the people controlling it
you're not going down there with the
state of the art I want the GPS on this
thing better be top-notch so they can
find me what are you bananas well I mean
if let's just say God forbid they don't
make it
they go to heaven and Saint Peter's
saying so what happened how'd you end up
here look you know we we try to go to
see the Titanic but I will tell you God
I hope you'll be proud of our ESG score
okay listen to me right now see that 25
year old God is woke you think you know
what no problem I mean we have now
rainbow colored uh Cloud so you can go
over there
what are you talking about I don't know
what kind of I definitely disco play
backgammon you know God God says hang on
man I invented the rainbow yeah oh no
except with one additional color that
was missing with the one that you have
but anyway all right last story here
before we wrap up I'm going to touch
this one as well MSNBC president open to
Trump Town Hall angering liberals MSNBC
president Rashida Jones indicated open
as to hosting a town hall with Donald
Trump if he requested stating would I
say yes it would be a conversation I
think you'd have to put parameters about
how to control the environment she
emphasized the networks discussions with
all the candidates on bringing their
viewpoints to the audiences through
various formats the statement Drew
criticism with former msnbc's Keith
Oberman calling for a new president at
the network and stating once again you
have Mo my most sincere apologies for
what MSNBC has become CNN Christine
Amanpour also disagree with allowing
Trump in this format saying I still
respectfully disagree with allowing
Donald Trump to appear in the particular
format so listen CNN does this Crystal
gets fired okay
now after Chrysler gets fired when CNN
does it all MSNBC did was criticize CNN
now they're saying they're open to the
idea of doing this so is this just the
whole point Tom that capitalism works
and if you need eyeballs you got to give
a guy like that the set because he's
going to bring eyeballs to the uh
Network
yeah let me read a translation there is
a translation that was of what he
actually said let me read it
um as ad sales and carriage fees are in
the tank we're very interested in
anything that will generate revenue for
MSM I retract my previous comments about
a trump debate because we could make a
hell of a lot of money here please
ignore my talent that is about to go
into orbit that's what that's exactly
okay well thank you for that time do you
think it's different than that I don't
think it is I think capitalism works and
I think capitalism wins because at the
end of the day yesterday Tico's having a
conversation with Lincoln we're
finishing up the book here with choose
your enemies why is that I can't wait to
launch this every time I read it I get
more excited about it yes anyway it's
going to be a while six months
but one of the conversations we're
having is hey he's asking hey Pat daddy
what's the difference between you know
uh what do you call it um a republic and
a uh democracy okay gotcha so hey we're
having this conversation a republic is
when
democracy is when the majority is
protected because you're listening to
the majority and a representative
Republic is when the individual is
protected from the majority as well as
the majority is also protected but the
individual is also protected in the
Republic you know he says well are we
Republican a democracy well I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible liberty and justice for all
right okay so it's like oh okay so
that's what it is yes
eventually in these types of settings
when these men
who founded America on this freaking
insane piece of paper the Constitution
man so lucky do you realize like how
shit's gonna hit the fan here and there
but but the level of gratitude we ought
to have for these folks that came up
with this you and I would have never met
none of us would have met here it's just
because of what these men did
1775 1776 imagine what these guys had to
do so so there is a protection to
protect the Constitution and there's
trust in known capitalism works the
reason why capitalism Works look at the
capitalists I myself when the company
sold PHP people got checks there's a
level of loyalty from us to each other
when that happens right anything you do
big nothing's going to be built big if
other people are also not participating
in the victory right now what's
happening with folks like msnbcc and
then guess what they're saying someone
behind closed doors they're having this
you know what the behind closer
conversation is it's not why are you
supporting Trump you know what the
conversation is hey what's up with this
loss we can't only do this for three
more months if we keep losing the kind
of money we're losing ground now you're
fired you know what call Trump hey
president Trump can you please come and
do this okay you've got to do it
capitalism works and capitalism exposes
[__] the longer you stick around and
you're like and I'm talking about real
Capital I'm not talking about crony
capitalism type of stuff eventually
somebody sits there and says
damn it you got to trust incentives
incentives makes everybody realize I
better get my act together anyways Yank
A great podcast today uh we we didn't
have in the schedule to do it but we
said let's go ahead and do it emergency
podcast made the announcement I
appreciate my phone is blowing up I got
so many messages right now people
sending me messages left and right to
everybody if I haven't got back go
Yankees maybe yesterday congratulations
again thank you thank you yesterday I
was getting back to Happy Father's Day
messages that I'm like listen man thank
you and happy belated Father's Day to
you my phone but I'm like anyways but uh
uh look a couple things you do need to
know we are talking to two or three big
names for the next live podcast at 59.90
live I'm telling you this right now you
will want to be at these but they're not
gonna stay I'm telling you right now
when we announce the text
you got to get your tickets because it's
gonna sell out ASAP and every time we do
this we have the sheriff there we have
security there we have guards there it's
no joke when we do these types of events
we're about to announce the next one
text award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again Rob if you can
put it on the bottom so they have a text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 just we just can't wait to
see you guys on our next live one
because the energy is going to be even
crazy with all the stuff that's going on
but if you do want to get registered for
the next one again text award podcast to
310-340-1132 have a great weekend
everybody take care bye bye